foreign
[Music]
you can't wait for him to come to you
so I can't I don't wait here and get
that right it's his intention you
already have
okay they got the first thing don't
don't wait okay so the first one it's uh
that's too late you see so you have to
already be in that communion with him
um you have to feel it it's a feeling
okay but if you wait
until you see it it's too late you're
not in the feeling this the feeling is
not in the eyes Okay so whatever I want
to feel it okay now after that so let's
rewind the film a little bit you'll kind
of help yourself by staying out
connected Can you see that okay you can
reach for him see he touched okay
and reach for him he never broke contact
there
and that'll help you
get that first rep
eventually
it's kind of like the first rep is uh
you have a double action single action
trigger
your double action first pull is a
little harder shot than the single
action subsequent pools okay but this
but in essence is the same trigger
control so you should reach you see but
after that don't set back up you're
gonna have to do that double action pull
over and over and maybe you're not there
for it okay
uh for you uh you don't launch it do
that see how I kind of hunched in like
that okay so you have a different
understanding
of what rooting is so you're you're
understanding is here like that do you
see but what this is gonna do is
compress your tonden field
so
I don't have that tension
in my body
I'm going to keep
Natural Spine off alignment
not
you've got can you guys see that okay so
here is my root
it's not a physical it's not a postural
thing
okay the next thing I would like you to
pay attention to is I'm I called it
ledging
okay
so Legend
is uh when you try to find a ledge on
him that you can push okay so if you
camera come closer
his little his wristbone right there do
you feel that ledge there so I can
physically push on that ledge or some
obvious ones is here at the elbow you
see there's a ledge there that you can
push
um so cast yourself with no ledge you
see how I'm doing that and then uh you
can work better on your
adhesions you get that like press
yourself
to uh by challenging yourself okay so
there's nothing wrong so see I can do I
can't do an adhesion on the ledge do you
see that but maybe I come here instead
you see and do the adhesion now
as I try to increase my skill okay
and then for all of you your torso is
going to move that's gonna help you
don't sit here with your shoulders in
place and your arms are moving
see that say my body is in place and
your arms move
my body moves with him
okay let's try it
straighten your back don't cave your
chest in
watch the ledging
watch The Legend
let's start over I
I shouldn't have to explain it over and
over
watch the hooking hooking is ledging
foreign
do you see here then you don't need to
do anything this this hand does it
you see his hands dirty you understand
you look lost okay so you because you
did that happened to you a lot because
what you tend to do is you open the arms
you see you open the arms and then the
arm the arm comes in and touches you
here see that or you feel it touching
you then so now you go and you're doing
this stuff you see look the arm touches
my torso do you see you got it okay do
you feel that friction there okay you
see so are you going to do the same
thing here
right you see so I don't need to clear
the arm the arm the arm touch part of my
body and I use that part of my body hey
do you see that yeah when you go like
this and you feel the arm go and you're
like oh again that's how they're you're
being attached to the arm just play the
feeling the feeling okay wherever the
arm goes does it not
then you won't have to defend yourself
so much see it doesn't matter if you
talk me I'll do that
[Music]
and you can break break if you can break
and then you come in you see
Brave
okay let's try it again don't if they
touch you you're it's the same
you touching them it's the same they're
touching you they say I touch control
the center okay yeah
okay that's it
reach more stay reaching don't come back
and wait stay in the relationship he's
over there
don't set your torso back
leave your torso reach go
better
there you go
thank you
okay
thanks
okay so now we're gonna keep all of
those things but let us play with the
amount of penetration we have in his
products okay
so I do and I wanna say
move past himself
see that I'm going out I'm I'm training
okay I'm trying to make it harder
be totally outside his face you see that
so before I see I go here that's going
to take something but this time I don't
wanna
okay that's what I'm trying to do move
boom
okay that's what we're doing
but
you don't want to start
pushing
flexing you gotta let it bounce and
project back out so you have to watch
for
your confusion between extension and
tension
see and from here I'm just pushing at
him and he actually has my center
missing and he's the the second you push
back in you give him your Center but
when you let it go into the ground it
takes his Center away okay so usually
what happens is you cast yourself with a
displacement of the Hara
your mind goes dichotomous
and then you just are tensing and
pushing with your arms okay
foreign
you're going into a uh
you disengage in between you're not
using the hint that I gave you or stay
engaged okay
so what's happening is as you push on
him do you see he has greater mass so he
you giving him your Center when you push
on him externally and that's what's
happening okay
when it's not happening is because
externally you have decreased his mass
in the Torso tilts do you see that but
uh it's still external okay
which one
so that first double action pulls a
okay
you gotta get in your Center
better
watch your your stomach crunching
it's a flexion it's not it's a it's not
it's an improper understanding of the
mechanics you don't need to do that all
right
foreign
crunching there okay
okay so I I understand that you
you watch her body okay so she's pushing
there's a there's a percussiveness to it
do you see that we'll do that same one
again
you see but now watch my body and see if
you see a percussiveness there there
isn't any do you see so what you what's
happening as you're observing the
training
is you see the percussion in the uke and
then you
you percussion as the Noggin that's not
it so now when you do your percussions
you're doing those external pushes do
you see so I I don't do those those
pushes she's pushing into me and I just
let that go to the ground that's all I'm
doing let it go to the ground so it
doesn't matter how much she she pushes
we're not going anywhere okay so you
could do a slow slow
you see so I used her Center oh
[Music]
okay and uh
as you go now so let's stop the the not
hit jerky okay verse 10 don't you don't
do that the energy does that and the UK
does it but not the number
okay your hands just move
and then what we'll do is as you're
going into projection
you have to I want you to bring
awareness to the slipperiness
Okay the reason you lose that adhesion
the eye key is again your external you
have too much Yong in the hand
and it starts to move opposite this hand
you you can only
uh I want you to feel this so I push you
see it's very slippery very slippery but
you see how it scrap it grabbed on to
you right so as you push on to me if I
say too much Yin
you you slipped you see that but if I'm
too much yawn I'll slip I have to match
you so as you come in I just keep
matching that you see and the friction
is increasing as we're going right so
you you're trying to push me if I go
live you see how you got slippery but in
the same way if I
over young you I will get slippery again
okay so you you have that feeling
okay and the more she pushes into me the
more young I have to do to match it do
you understand and the less you push
into me the less young I have to do
there's the stickiness it's still there
you see okay so maybe you start to feel
like you're slipping so what do you have
to do
you gotta get more okay so you're like
oh I'm starting to throw but I'm
slipping do you see you'll start hearing
more and you'll come back okay got it
now
it's always going to be like that you're
always going to raise your young Indian
levels in response to what I'm doing and
also as a reaction to what I'm doing to
you so for example you might have a
great deal of young on the initial push
do you see when you have perfect posture
but as I start to take that posture
you're going to not have as much yawn
and if I keep the initial yawn level and
I start to tilt you you're losing it on
this arm because this bottom arm down
here you see that and I keep pushing
then eventually I slip so it has to
decrease in order so that I can have the
stickiness
constantly changing constantly changing
okay you see that you have to change
your levels okay so usually as I have
coached a lot of people is you smell
the throw at this young level and not
realizing her yin and young levels are
changing and that's where you start to
see that arm slit so what you want to do
instead is the feeling if I want to be
stuck here I just here at the right arm
you see if you feel it okay if I want to
be stuck here I just feel that I don't
really care about your throat
you understand
all right so uh just uh I'm gonna do the
same Journal if you're gonna give me
that arm I'm gonna use that arm
and I'm paying attention to where
they're I am
sticking or slipping okay with the same
task of get her you're right yes okay
don't disconnect like that
all right
[Music]
okay
I'm paying attention
how much slip I'm doing and then I'm
gonna try to
do the coaching tip okay
foreign
all right
switch rules
you gotta displace the center in this
drill
you you keep disconnecting your center
it's not healthy okay you don't want
that energy going into a deflated
taunted okay
we'll switch rules
you don't jerk
displace
this place
look at him
your your mind gets taken by your eyes
so you should look at him until you can
free your mind from your gaze okay
here I want you to play and we're gonna
now play uh with the surface of his
tandem so the last one I'm trying to get
in
on this one I'm gonna touch this time
then I'm touching it right now you feel
that okay but I will not
displace it I'll just move it
okay this is going to make for a very uh
light you'll feel how light detection
okay very light
not oh okay I'm just kissing his tongue
dead that's all I'm doing
I touch touching it but then not
displacing it just turning it
I want to get there because I want to
show you some another drill you can do
okay
foreign
yes you were just getting out of the way
okay you're right you're you're just
getting out of the way so in other words
you're just going here and just trying
to turn
wait I'm gonna move
move that thing
can you see that okay but I'm not here
boom you feel that see there's a
displacement see so I'm right on the
cusp of it so you can see
you see okay I'm right on the cusp of it
I'm not gonna get out of the way okay
are you right okay here we are if I go
any deeper I'm going to start to splice
it you see but now I use this connection
stay there please
and I'm going to move the front of your
palm Den field
they're not going to get out of the way
you say so
there it is you see that and if I just
get out of the way nothing's gonna
happen here wait I'm gonna move that
you see I'm gonna move it you move it
not even here I'm not going to not move
it you see again you can see a little
deeper there's the projection you see
okay so I'm here I'm not going to get
out of the way
I'm going to move just the surface of it
so for example
you that's where you came from right
pull back towards there
you see okay I I have the center you see
a lot of pressure increase more friction
increases here you see that so I'm gonna
move
that Center so I'll show you something
else that you could tell the difference
by
so the first difference was you're right
on the cusp of the projection
do you see that
second one is if you tried to reverse
you couldn't okay and then the third one
will use that same angle again there it
is right there
oh it's right there you see don't do
that move this okay and if I void
entirely notice where you want to fall
okay once I once you start to fall
you see
I want you to pay attention
as you go just want you to feel it
look how close you are
watch watch how you will have the idea
here's where I'm going to fall but Watch
What Happens
the further okay so and I want you to
pay attention as we go along with the
drill that that's what's happening
is any further than you want it together
see further than you wanted to go okay
you see that because I'm just on the
surface
but with the same control if I if we're
here and I just turn out of the way you
just fall right there you can feel that
you could go back if you wanted to
just pay attention right but I want to
have this this thing oh
okay
let's try it again
further than she wants
there you go
try not to hook a hook is ledging
you gotta penetrate a little bit more
initially
just don't displace
then move the front of it a little
better
trust you can't ledge you don't ledge
there's no need
they got slippery right
and you ledged on the outside hand don't
hook wherever you're touching is all you
need
you keep ledging the yin hand
s better
this is falling where she is wants to
right you have to take her beyond that
okay I'll let you play both ones the
penetration one
maybe okay I think you eat more easily
find what I'm about to show you
from what happens so when you have their
Center you you obviously have control of
their center right so he goes well and
we're we're already we're we're here you
see oh
okay but I'm taking control at that
point you see and what I want to happen
is I want him to give me control and the
way he'll give me control you see how
you're you're ledging on me you see that
okay so once he's ledging on me I can
void and he'll lose his balance and we
it's just a drill I want to be able to
tell when you ledged on me and then I
want to practice
non-reactionary behavior of I'm Legend
you back I am going to just die on the
technique okay so you'll find this much
easier if you're doing this moving his
Center and then you just you'll feel him
on him and then you'll just just let
your arms drop okay move his Center Let
It Go okay that that's our drill because
the the first drill is really about
releasing and inside internally you see
and here at this moment someone's
pushing on you and the uncultivated mind
will push back
do you see that so we're going to use
that stressor as the opportunity to
develop the releasing skill you got it
but you also have the desire of
accomplishing the throw because you're
not gonna you're gonna release the throw
too do you see that and they should just
fall okay
let's try
you're like only releasing your hands
release everything let your whole arms
drop your whole mind drops you totally
disengage so you got to take her a
little further right you gotta wait for
her to ledge on you you got to take her
further she'll ledge on you drop
that's right
so let me demonstrate it
it was probably a little hard for you to
see
okay
so uh when I when I move her so there it
is you see how I move in your Center and
when she lifts down to where you live
she'll be right here did you feel that
okay the legend is when you're using me
to hold your balance up okay so I'm in a
mover Center when I feel the ledge there
it is right there I let that ledge go so
I'm not going to just uh take her and
then stop
you see that that's kind of what you
were doing I'm going to take her into it
and there it goes right there
so everything drops on my body I want I
want to top to the head to the bottom a
complete release okay structure
intention and tension okay
yeah it's a little hard getting rid of
the attention too you're right now you
your attention is wanting her to fall
don't let go of that too
your let your whole body relax
release
don't don't know yeah I don't want to do
it physically I want to do it internally
I don't want to do it externally I don't
I don't need to act like I got my pillow
out and went to sleep so you don't need
to Crunch your spine again
just let go of all of it
internally
still got tension in your glutes and
lower back
same thing it's still in your glutes
you got to make sure he's ledging on you
so that time you went externally in and
we didn't have the initial connection
let's cycle through
you can feel like you're and see if you
could see it too there's like a a
slowness to the turning off to the
releasing and it's also not complete
there's still Parts you're still
don't crunch your spine
if she hadn't yet ledged you have to
feel it
see
yeah
feeling is don't you don't go oh about
now I should be able to do it okay you
have to feel her press on you
when she's pressing on you a lot there
you go
again you see the stuttering releasing
breathe
watch the hunch
release all the way
hands drop in space
drop more
you don't you don't pull them down they
just drop
better
foreign
so think in terms of that friction you
feel that friction you see right there
it is right there right here it is right
here okay
so when I heard and you ledge on me
here and see how heavy you made that
hand it's the it's the
friction that I'm getting away okay so
for example uh I won't take that hand
down but watch what's gonna happen to
your to your body
without hand pay attention
what's happening it's slipping do you
see that
you see that okay
so I'm changing those
uh yin yang values ratio to now generate
a slip so even if I move my Hound uh
here I'm under you see I'm under do you
see that I snapped that I just move out
of the way
I change the value so that she starts
slipping do you feel it again look you
see look look look look look you see so
again some of you ended up on the
shoulder
right and you see there's me there's me
increasing the value you see that don't
feel this pay attention look what's
happening look you see that what you see
do you get that so it's not that when
you end up on the shoulder it's not that
you go like that because they'll come
back into the yin space you created so
she's on the shoulder I'm pushed with it
you see well when it's time to die I I
let that shoulder go hyper you into your
value and you become slippery okay do
you understand that okay
uh any questions or comments
yes
it is crazy but not if you understand in
terms of Yin and young values so so for
two surfaces to have friction they must
have a value of uh you know they must
equal value of x
do you see okay well which factors go
into X
yin and yang there's different ratios
you see that so if you don't have those
ratios then you can't create the
friction but likewise if I don't want
friction I'll play that ratio for
slipperiness you see
okay that's how it is
most of my practice yeah yeah exactly
that's what you want and then you can
just release it and the person doesn't
have their balance anymore because you
you were using me to hold your balance
up you see and you can just yeah you can
just begin you just release that and now
you don't have a pattern or you could if
you wanted to right you could let it go
into you and into the ground and come
back out do you see and project with it
but if I want you to slip I'm going to
totally release it and you'll just
even when as mage I had posture I wasn't
using posture when it came to try that
release I had that sort of internal
catch as if I was falling yeah even if I
wasn't yeah yeah interesting yeah no I I
I'd like to use that to springboard on
the comment I've made is like your
release is really slow
and uh and then very partial so it kind
of reminds me like if there's you know
every once in a while I'll tell the kids
hey shut the lights off and it's like
taking forever for the lights to go off
and I'll usually go hey shut the light
off you know what I mean that was like
that on my release hey release it's like
I am
your kid is walking to there but it's
just taking longer you know or you have
those knobs where you change the
illumination and I go no all the way not
halfway right it's kind of looking it
looked like that but it's just a matter
of we got to get reps we got to get the
feeling and then we can be comfortable
with it right anything that you have to
do faster is going to be more intense
and that is that means more skill okay
because skill is both it's a skill is a
an increase in uh how fast you can do it
how long you can hold it right and under
what conditions you can do it okay so
it's a higher skill
anything else yes I was trying to
find architectures that would give me a
like a grosser feedback I was having a
hard time really getting a sense
especially with Virginia maybe because
of the weight the scrutiny between us
that feeling that she was really ledging
on me yeah so the techniques towards the
end there I was doing things to try to
either get a reaction out of her where
she would push back yeah and that would
give me a more gross uh noticeable point
that I would try to release whereas
before it was too subtle and or I didn't
have captured I hadn't captured enough
with her Center to have had been I was
like in the dark just what am I trying
to release here yeah I'm not really
knowing I was wondering if you had any
Maybe
yeah aim it too much but no I don't
think so I think but you you tried for a
different way of generating her leg time
okay so what you did is like a the
push-pull okay so I push you're gonna
you're gonna pull or vice versa you know
you're trying to and then so you're
trying to like push and turn and she'll
push into you you see that and now she's
ledging
um
but the one that I gave is if you take
them past the point where they think
they're going to roll
you take them past that they will ledge
on you because they had a particular
capture of the Mind here is that where
I'm going to lower my shoulder and the
second you go Oh no you're not
that's when they finally that's what
kazushi is that's how I'd like for you
to understand kazushi it's not a a
simple tilting of the body it's I have
your Center do you see that so when she
goes to push here it's already kazushi
this to me this is kazushi as opposed to
you're here to stand still and I go like
that that's not pizushi you see your
athlete is going to be able to get out
of this or work from here but here you
feel that that's kazushi in the same way
because I have her I have her Center
look you see
okay so the same way here you are not in
a tilt do you see that and you would
think that if once I go here you see
there I have your Center again
you're actually in kazushi okay so
anything you move right now you'll see
that what what the uninitiate would
recognize as balance Reiki but I've
already broken her balance because she
does not control the center of her body
do you see that so and she starts to
move whatever she do see what happened
to her base you see that
so when she when I move that Center and
she wants to roll there she's trying to
take control back of her Center do you
see that but when I go no not there over
here and this is all that pressure
increase right here and here's where I
let it slip you see that so I find out
it's much easier to get somebody to
ledge on you than to
just push at you okay but if you wanted
to
have something similar to that I would
still keep with what I just described
what is kazushi is you controlling the
center okay and how do you control the
center is that I am taking her young
energy right and I am aiming it back
into her Tom Den field that's now that's
my condent field okay so if you want for
example I could project you see
oh there and then let it die
because even though you're going the
other way you will push on me as as much
as it makes no tactical sense you just
see people reaching for things and right
now she she she is going to re let's try
to do it let me try to explain it okay
so I'm gonna get the projection there is
I'll show it right here said boom there
it is okay and you see how her hand went
out do you see that and so when her when
her she's going out her hand with that
that's what I let her talk
that would probably be better because
the way they might push at you from a
reactionary push-pull right you might
not have their Tom den and then they
will not ledge on you in the way that
I'm describing for the Catalyst for this
releasing trip okay